Huge thanks for the shout out!
To what do I owe this pleasure?
FTC calls me: "wildly popular... PewDiePie."
If you ever meet me in person
please refer to me as the wildly popular, PewDiePie.
Basically, this happened:
PewDiePie and other youtubers took money
from Warner Brothers for positive game
reviews.
Now that's fucked up..(sigh) I am just
disappointed.
This is all over my twitter feed. People
are saying 'PewDiePie took corporate money
to not disclose paid game reviews #Shame.'
'Warner Brothers and
PewDiePie's shady influencer marketing.'
So... shady.
It's disgusting. 'Bloggers and influencers
have responsibility to disclose'
'Now that PewDiePie got caught getting paid off by publishers to shill for games-'
'can we hate him now?' Can we just hate PewDiePie now? I don't really know what
he does but I never liked him and
now I got a reason to hate that son of a
bitch
he got paid; and he didn't disclose it.
That's disgusting.
That's despicable, fuck that asshole - oh wait, no wait it's right there.
First of all, this is two years ago.
Second of all, it's right there... It's
right there, it's right there.
No one mentions this, no one! 'This video
was sponsored by Warner Brothers'
Basically what happened, was that a lot
of youtubers were involved in the
sponsorship; but since I'm the biggest
YouTuber
my name is the only one that pops up and
basically what happened was that we
weren't required to disclose.
I still did it. Some other YouTubers
actually didn't disclose it, but i'm
getting all the shit for it and it's
kind of bullshit
Yes, I could have disclosed it better, I
could have put it above the fold
So basically all these news articles are
using me as a clickbait putting my name
to shame when I didn't even do anything
wrong
The Verge, Variety, Polygon, Recode,
Mashable... the list goes on.
and this person put it out pretty, pretty
well. 'The FTC found that Warner
Brothers was at fault and The Verge used
PewDiePie's name as clickbait.
The reddit post says 'this is a terrible
article with a clickbait title-
-if you're interested in this issue-
-you're better off simply reading FTC's
press release. Of course Warner Bros did
not pay PewDiePie for a positive review as
PewDiePie generally doesn't do reviews'
Everyone is calling me a reviewer, and
that is unethical for me to do a
positive review, but I'm not a reviewer; and
if you watch the video this is what I say.
*video* "Thank you for liking
and commenting on this video as always
bros and thank you for hanging out with
me today, I had a lot of fun playing this game so I hope you did as well."
That's disgust-  (disgusting)
I had fun playing the game? Fuck you, he would never have said that. Piece of shit-
How dare you 2014 PewDiePie enjoy a game,
that is critically acclaimed. Disgusting.
Can we all just hate PewDiePie now?
What they paid PewDiePie to do; was a paid
promotion. Which is perfectly legal, as
long as it's disclosed; which it was.
"which it was"
Why is no-one mentioning this? The
headline is misleading the people
getting paid to the reviews are failing
to disclose that, were other less known
YouTubers who would bring in less clicks.
according to the FTC, it was the
responsibility of Warner Brothers, to ensure
that YouTubers taking part in promotion
correctly disclose this fact
Okay, it goes on. You get the point.
Thank you Nicole Sund.
I appreciate that you did this. Here's an
important point, this is two years ago and
the FTC didn't release
guideline specific to YouTube until
2015 and this video was in 2014.
I do want to say that because of this,
back then, YouTube paid promotion was a bit
of a grey area.
Nevertheless, I still disclaimed it. It's
there in the description -_- but this is how
it looks like today; I'll make a verbal
mention before the video even begins
"this video was brought to you by Loot Crate" and
the top line in the description; mentions
it as well and this is so you bros can
know if the video is sponsored or not
right away
I'm all for disclaiming content I have
no problem with it
I'm gonna keep doing it and finally, 'The Verge is trash for using PewDiePie to get
views when all the other YouTubers who
didn't disclose the Warner Brothers with our
sponsorship at all. This happens time, and
time again, with media they take- they
take someone popular like me, and they
run whatever story is going to get the
more clicks, and you know, my name gets
run into the ground and a lot of these
articles are saying like we're still
waiting for PewDiePie for a reply
we're still waiting for PewDiePie to
respond to this horrific act
that he has committed
I don't fucking need you. I have an
audience
I can talk to them. You're
literally insignificant and that's why
you're pulling this shit because I think
you know it.
This is my response. Now excuse me while
I go play Bear Simulator, the greatest
game that has ever been made. - and also I
have to disclose this video was
sponsored by CSGOLotto.
Thanks for grouping me with those people, Polygon.
Really appreciate it.
We're practically the same, honestly
thanks for people who saw through this
bullshit and commented, and boasted about
it I really really appreciate that
people see past the headlines because
the problem with this is people read the
headline and that's all that they
get out of it. If I did something wrong
I should have- I should be paying the
consequences, in this case I don't think
I did anything wrong. but that's all for
now
I'm sorry this had to take up a video,
I'll see you bros in the next one.
*Brofist*